(Furious Snapping)
The thing that we learned is that laptops, when you unplug them, everything clocks down.
They dont run at full power
Running laptops by themselves on your back, not gonna work.
We needed real power, real energy density.
So now we got laptops, plugged in. They've been running VR when they're plugged in, flawless.
Now we gotta trick the laptop into thinking its plugged in.
[Pop]
Whoops
I'm trying to build a backpack mounted PC because I really want to play VR without wires.
I've been trying to do this for years.
(Nick: Yeah, this sounds kinda familar)
Yeah, it has a desktop 980 in it
Ugh, it overheated again
Yep, its kinda familiar. Same old story.
I didn't have the right hardware for it, and now I do.
So I'm going to take this battery, full charge is 25. 2 volts
I'm going to step it down to that 19.5 that that laptop requires
Its a little tricky, I gotta make sure I do it right
I'm gonna run this battery into the step down converter
I'm going to run the step down converter through a power analyzer so I can see how much amperage is being pulled through it.
And then I need to get the plug
Thats been the hardest part, the plug for the laptop.
So this is an Origin laptop. It uses this dang plug that I can't find it.
It's female pin sockets, on a male plug
So it's really hard to search for it in Google because typing typing female or male on the plug doesn't yield you the correct results.
I narrowed it down to it's brother component.
Its the Kykon KPPX, or the KPPJ
Uuuhh (laughs)
Rant complete
I ordered a piece that might work it might not
These are solder wires
Soldering Iron
And I need to solder plugs on the end of the wire, so I can plug it in
If you're ever buying a soldering iron, get one that has a temperature controlled head.
Its basically one that has a thermostat in it
It will hold the heat you need all the time
It will never overheat and burn the solder on the end
It will never underheat, it just holds the perfect temperature.
Its $40 compared to the usual like $10 or $20 you might pay
Its worth it, its worth every penny
I have to really be careful that these don't touch
And short each other out
That would be bad news
Let's be a little extra safe
So I put some heat-shrink tubing on the end of this
(vroom)
and turn on this hair dryer
(vrooming intensifies)
Can you hold this wire for me?
Now the wire might get hot okay
(Nick: Okay, should I get gloves?)
No
Cool, I'll take this from you now
(screwdriver noises)
(vigorous popping)
(squeak)
The problem with talking about this stuff
like when I talk about film techniques
Is that I know what I'm talking about when I'm talking about VFX and film techniques
Where as I don't know
I don't know what I'm talking about when I talk about this
And I'm still figuring it out as I go so its like
I have long pauses of silence while I think about how I'm going to solve a problem
Such as, here's the plug that I've been looking for
for a loooooong time, finally found it
It cost like $10 just to order this one
The bottom is positive, the top is negative
(Cmike: what color is positive?)
Red
And its split across 2 pins because
the power draw from the laptop is so big that you need to get a 4 pin connector and just have 2 of the pins be the same thing for each half of it
And now
Now I need to solder this 10 gauge wire
to these pins, which are definitely not 10 gauge soldering pins
and I can't overlap it
I should probably start by just putting some solder in it.
There's a little bit of
solder on your soldering iron, a little bit of solder on your connectors, and a little bit of solder on your wire
thats the best way to do it
I've gotta bridge both of these bottom pins with this wire, which I can do like this
But I can't have it touch the top pins
Its almost like I should just solder it to the wire like that
get a bunch of solder, thats all really toxic smoke, and heat up the wires
and the wires that get hot should wick away the metal from my soldering iron
this isn't like, exciting, huge problems here, this is just
This is just care and attention
But if there are any mistakes here, if I screw this up, than I got a long time to wait before I get my next connector
(Cmike: Im surprised you didn't order two)
Yeah, that's not the kind of guy I am
This is way better than a wet sponge
Freddie introduced me to this
Its just like a steel wool kind of thing with a bunch of like solder flux in it
and then all your solder from the tip of the iron falls of into the dish
it does a way better job of cleaning the iron than a wet sponge does
(vroom)
Now for the other side, ha ha ha
stripping a wire
Something about melting metal makes me feel really cool
And now I have to solder
If you can look here, if you get above it you can see there's the pin coming up
and then I'm just gonna do this
(vroom)
This plug, I think I did a good job
I need to put an XT60 connector on the other end of that wire
Specifically female
And this is the part where you can't forget to put the heat shrink tubing on the wire
before you solder the stuff on it
This makes it a lot easier to connect the two because  all I have to do is heat them up and stick them together
And all I have to do here is squeeze it down
and once the heat transfers to the wire, it should get down to the solder I put in there and melt
Over here
whoops
(inhales)
Oh, its just the pin twists inside of it
(vroom)
So Jake is good at carpentry and wood craftsmanship
but I feel like I've gotten pretty good at soldering and wire-work
(Cmike: You two could build a house together)
Jake could build the frames, and I could put in the electrical
You see, being an electrician would be fun, I would actually enjoy being an electrician
That was so clean, it was the cleanest connection I've done yet.
Its like sitting right in there
It is. Your eyes do not deceive you, it is that connector
(Wren: I knew it.)
(vroom)
Its all done!
I can plug a battery in, and I can plug it in to a laptop.
(Wren: Its pretty sweet)
Here's the thing, I can't dial in the amperage until I plug it in to the laptop.
Um, hey, you're leaving right now aren't you
(Wren: I'm takin off, yeah, why is that?)
Umm
This is done, I could try it
(Wren: I- ok, you can try it)
Do you want to wait like 5 minutes for me to go get the laptop and the battery?
(Wren: I was going to take Obie to a dog park)
Oh
(Wren: before it gets dark)
ok, we'll do this tomorrow
They are indeed.
You're holding this one upside down.
(Wren: I am?)
(Spencer: Yeah, see how there's a flat bit here with a little indenture)
(Spencer: one more, there you go, thats the same way)
(Cmike: How long did it take you to find that piece?)
Ugh, it took me weeks to find that piece
no, its stable
(Wren: nice)
(Wren: Uhh, thats odd)
(Wren: Why are these wires backwards?)
let me look at it
Oh no
(Spencer: Well, they're reversed over here too)
Oh, hold up, hold up, hold up, hold up
(Spencer: Red is going to)
Oh, you're right
(laughs)
(Spencer: Well, its reversed reversed, so that means its going the right way at the end)
No, I'm going to fix that
You're right, I connected that wrong, ok, let me just double check all of these now
(Wren: The flat side of the XT60 has to be positive)
(Wren: This has the flat side being negative)
(Spencer: Some soldering later...)
(Wren: So its just the XT60 that is flipped, the wires connected to the board are fine)
(All: yes)
(Spencer: Uh ok, we ca- [snap])
(snap)
Well whatever, I did it
(Furious Snapping)
I'm super paranoid about this now, but it looks correct
(Wren: Yeah, that matches up)
(Wren: Flat is red, red flat)
we're getting 19.6 to 19.5 volts
(Spencer: So the computer is on right now, and we are at 62% on battery on the inside of it)
Kay
(D: So there's a chance of frying this brand new Origin laptop we just got?)
(Wren: Yeah, in fact the chances are quite high, it will probably be dead after this.)
(D: Why are you doing that?)
(laughing)
No, I'm not gonna fry it, well-
(D: Don't do that, use another laptop to test it)
(Wren: No, we need to use this one specifically)
(Spencer: There's no other laptop with that type of connector in the back of it)
This is the only one that pulls that much voltage, and with this kind of connector
(Cmike: Could you turn off that fan?)
So, here's my thought
I've gathered you all here today to hopefully help absolve me to insure the blame if I fry this laptop
(D: Yeah, what are you gonna do if this laptop breaks?)
call Origin
Battery running to voltage converter, we can see it right now putting out 19.5 volts, its going into the plug
Its all soldered as you normally would this stuff
Do you guys see anything that could possibly fry this laptop?
(D: Yeah, that whole thing right there.)
(Wren: I love how nervous D is. Im not nervous at all, Im sure this is gonna go completely fine)
(Spencer: Aside from actually putting the pins in there)
(Spencer: and being able to get the actual voltage readings from inside there)
(Spencer: we tested it inside there, we're getting the right voltage here, like, it should be fine)
(Cmike: He made the mistake of putting the wrong cables in the wrong places, but he fixed that now)
(D: Oh, thats good)
(Wren: Hey, its plugged in)
(Spencer: And we're showing it's charging)
I'm pulling 5 amps
Its goin allright
(Wren: Its workin, Its workin!)
It is pulling 11 consistently now
We're doin it!
We're hittin 220 watts
(Wren: Is anything heatin up?)
Well, there's heat coming out of the computer
(Wren: Woah)
(Spencer: and then uhh, just like one spot on this)
I'm not to worried about that
(Spencer: No, Im not worried about that because of the huge heat sink it has)
(Spencer: But I mean...)
(Wren: Ooh, these wires are heating up)
(Spencer: A little, but like, we're not talking about much)
You just put it in front of this vent
(Wren: Dang it)
But like right in the middle here is the coolest it can be
Yeah, not too much
Its no more hot than this stuff
Okay
Now the real test here is to now take this and plug it into our laptop that's hooked up to the Vive
(Cmike: Where's that?)
Its next door
Its gonna be on a backpack, and all the power to run the laptop is also in the backpack.
(Clint: Woah)
And then I can be in there swingin swords without getting caught in cables.
(Clint: That's awesome. Thats so much better)
(Clint: Is that how they have it at The Two Bit Circus or is there wires everywhere?)
Uh, they have some that are backpack mounted and they have some that are wires
(Cmike: What's The Two Bit Circus?)
(Wren: The Two Bit Circus is that VR arcade down the street that we all went to last week and you were like "No, im gonna paint my minnies instead" and we were like "Alright"
So this is the production laptop we're currently using for Node
We run the VR system through it
I've unplugged it from the wall, its plugged into the Vive right now
Im going to plug it into my mobile power supply
And Im gonna run VR, and if VR runs at full frame rate, than it works.
(Cmike: How long have you been working on this?)
Three years (laughs)
allright
And the verdict is...
Oh, the frame rate is butter smooth
(laughs) Runs great
So I got the laptop working at full power when its not plugged in to the wall.
Its pulling all the electricity from this battery
And I've tricked the laptop into thinking that this battery and this system is actually house power basically running into the laptop
So nothing is being downclocked, everything is running at full power
And I can run VR in full frame rate
Now the last thing I have to do is put this in a backpack, so I can be free to move around, without any wires holding me down
Allright, I'm going into the game.
You know what, this is more like relief that it work as opposed to like celebration. (laughs)
(Cmike: Do you feel like Harry Potter?)
Uh, I feel like the first man in space
Ryan Gosling, the first man in space
I feel relief that it's working, and I've got plenty of improvement to do to this rig.
I want to have it so that its like hanging up there
When its time for us to record VR games, I can just walk up, hit play, close the laptop, put it on, and then like strut into the middle of the room
And I can just like do this, without any entanglement, I can just be wherever I want
I've got this up and running. I've got more work to do to make it perfect, and of course I've gotta play some sick VR games.
So subscribe if you want to see me continue working on this and turning it into something special
The ultimate video game machine
(Inaudible)
Brandon is doing a lot of VR development, and they have Vive Pros and their 2.0 trackers
which let you have a much much bigger volume, so theoretically
We could we replicate the building in 3D, and I could run through the entire building wearing VR
I think we're gonna try and do something like that.
Shout out to Node, if you guys haven't heard about node, its our gaming channel
We do a lot of VR there
These guys are working on the videos right now
You'll see this in action on Node
Consider hoppin over there and takin a look
Thanks for watching everybody, this has been like 3 years to get this up and running
Finally got it, finally got the power working.
Now I just need to make it extra slick and easy to use.
The challange of engineering!